what if we humans could live somewhere
outside of Earth say the moon obviously
we can't just pack our stuff and move
there today but what if we terraformed
it reshaped it into Earth's image how
long would it take us to turn our
natural satellite into a habitable place
what would this Earth Moon look like
would this even be possible this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
terraform the moon wondering why we
chose the moon and not Mars with water
ice buried beneath its surface the red
planet seems to be the best candidate to
serve as our second earth but with zero
experience terraforming we should
consider colonizing our natural
satellite first it gets twice as much
sunlight as Mars and it's just a
three-day trip from us in short it would
take us less time and money to construct
a decent earth on our moon so how
exactly do we engineer a habitable
planet just to be clear we're not
talking about building a permanent moon
base we'd go nuts and actually transform
the moon into an earth just a smaller
one for starters we'd need to build an
atmosphere and here's the fun part
to do that we'd need to bombard our moon
with a hundred water ice comets ice
droids we'd find them flying all around
the earth these comets would crash into
the moon's surface they fill the moon's
Plains with water and disperse carbon
dioxide along with water vapour and a
little bit of ammonia and methane all
these gases would gather near the
surface creating an atmosphere the newly
formed seas would reflect much more
sunlight making the moon appear five
times brighter when seen from Earth
these ice droids would also give the
moon a momentum
they'd make our satellites spin close to
an earth-like cycle the more comets we
batter into the
a faster it would rotate a lunar day
would drop down from an incredible 28
earth days to just 60 hours since our
satellite wouldn't rotate on its axis at
the same rate it orbits the earth
anymore it would no longer be tidally
locked to our planet for earthers this
would mean we'd be able to see the dark
side of the moon although it wouldn't be
dark but how do we save the newly built
lunar atmosphere from being stripped
away by solar winds we'd have a couple
of options the first one is easy moon's
own rotation would generate a dynamo
effect that dynamo could awaken the
moon's once active magnetic field that
would keep the atmosphere in place if
that doesn't work out we'd have to place
a gigantic shield in orbit that shield
would work as an artificial bow shock
making up for a missing magnetic field
when that's all sorted we'd bring in
genetically engineered plants suitable
for growing on the moon's stony ground
we'd also drop some algae that would
release oxygen into the air that would
be the start of life on the moon finally
after many decades of hard and costly
work we'd send the first human colony to
settle down on the first man-made planet
the terraformed moon would get very warm
from greenhouse effects it would be
mostly cloudy too and with tides as high
as 20 meters surfers might want to make
the trip living on the moon would be
just like living in Florida but with 1/6
of the Earth's gravity the moon settlers
would be able to jump as high as 3
meters off the ground remaining in the
air for 4 seconds and if they were
really fit and full of stamina they'd be
able to run across the moon's lake this
is because running on the water requires
less muscle power if you do them reduce
gravity would you move to the moon to
experience all that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]